You know the stories but what if one thing changed
everything that doesn't sound ominous at all on
august 11th expect the unexpected it cannot
be let's be honest we've been through weirdos
and ask yourself the question what if
it appears we have a common enemy i guess
i have to freestyle then reality reality
it's changeable
where you want to be that's the
question isn't it every universe
is different each one
unique slow down a little bit there's a few people
in the room that don't understand not me i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
i am the watcher i observe all that
transpires here but i do not cannot will not
out of bird interfere ravager never
flies solo i said never flies solo ah
is that some kind of catchphrase
you had me worried for a second
journey to face the unknown
and ponder the question
what if
Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel
what if trailer video there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs spider-man becoming a version
of doctor strange the cloak of levitation there
it's mister doctor spider-man to you there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
i will be doing videos for all the episodes
they're literally starting in a couple weeks
but if you were wondering this isn't supposed to
be galactus i think a lot of people immediately
went to that just because of the shape of his
head here the silhouette but it's actually ultron
after he's gone final boss form ultron with all
six infinity stones and after he's taken over
vision's body so he becomes like a living infinity
gauntlet with all six infinity stones embedded
in his body like darkest timeline ultron but the
whole thing here was spider-man becoming a version
of doctor strange he's wearing doctor strange's
cloak of levitation from the mcu like the benedict
cumberbatch version of the cloak of levitation
we've been seeing in all the marvel movies so far
everyone cue up the clips from spider-man into
the spider-verse and it's a no on the cape
i think it's cool take that off it's
disrespectful spider-man doesn't wear a cape
i think this is a cape he does have a slightly
different version of the original stark tech
suit from captain america civil war and spider-man
homecoming just because there are a few very very
minor differences some people think that it's
meant to be a version of the suit that he's
wearing in that new disneyland and disney world
avengers campus theme park because all the stuff
that marvel did at those theme parks incorporate
designs from other time periods in the mcu a
really good example is the version of the iron man
armor that you see if you go to those theme parks
it's actually the iron man mark 80 and it's meant
to be a version of his armor from between avengers
infinity war and avengers end game because if you
remember in avengers infinity war his nanotech
armor that he whips out was the mark 50 but when
we get to avengers end game and we see him whip
out his armor in that final battle it's the mark
85 so people are like what happened to those 34
armors in that five year time jump where did they
all go but the whole thing with spider-man during
the what if series as far as we know is that
this peter parker who looks just like a slightly
older version of tom holland's peter parker and
spider-man far from home is being referred to
on the series as zombie hunter spider-man so it
sounds like wherever the character is introduced
in the marvel what if multiverse timelines
he winds up being a bigger part of the marvel
zombies episodes or multiple episodes the big
change from marvel comics what if series is that
they're actually doing a more serialized version
of those stories for the tv show the original
comic book was just a series of one-offs like you
would see a what-if story was spider-man but then
in the next issue they would go to a completely
disconnected story with a different character
and it was all treated as if these were happening
in alternate timelines but it sounds like on the
series everything will be way more connected
because you'll see the characters show up in
one episode then they'll continue on into the
next episode as things sort of spin up as they
put together this multiverse avengers team they're
calling their team the guardians of the multiverse
but because the scenes they're using to introduce
them to sort of highlight their characters are big
twists on classic avengers scenes is sort of like
they're combining the concept of the guardians of
the galaxy with the avengers and the idea of the
multiverse after what happened with loki and them
spinning up into the true version of the marvel
mcu multiverse it's not going to be quite as
complicated as it seems but it just sounds like
this whole idea with marvel zombies and these
characters going crazy avengers turning into
zombies it's not gonna be like they do marvel
zombies in one episode and then completely fix
everything within 20 minutes like there'll be some
storyline about how the watcher captain carter the
darker version of doctor strange start bringing
the multiverse avengers team together across the
episodes and as events unfold something happens
that leads to marvel zombies and spider-man just
gets swept up in that fight but as you can see
his spider-man symbol on his chest is fairly
simple to mcu tom holland's spider-man symbol
the stark tech suit looks very similar so
even though iron man has what seems like a
very different twist on his origin story involving
kilmonger at some point during that peter parker
seems like he'll have a similar origin story to
mcu tom hall and spider-man get involved with tony
stark maybe they have a twist on the joke of the
stark industry's internship and then he gets that
version of the suit from tony stark and as things
spiral out of control marvel zombies happen and as
for the whole doctor strange cloak of levitation
twist if you think about it this way the main
version of doctor strange on the what if series
is meant to be a darker version of the character
it seems like just based on the toys here the
labels they're calling him doctor strange supreme
i'm assuming because during his origin story
when they introduce the character he winds up
taking the title of sorcerer's supreme by force
from the ancient one so he becomes sorcerer's
supreme in a slightly different way like it seems
like he winds up fighting a less dark version of
himself and also winds up fighting the ancient one
so things just go completely off the rails during
his origin story the way the producers talked
about him he takes a quote-unquote darker path
i think he's meant to be more of an anti-hero
version of the character but as you could
probably tell he is being voiced by benedict
cumberbatch and his cloak seems very different
from the regular cloak of levitation the one
that spider-man is wearing during this seems like
the regular cloak of levitation that we've seen
this whole time in the marvel movies so far but
i'm assuming that doctor strange supreme here
just gives spider-man the cloak of levitation
because he isn't using it he doesn't need it and
there's some massive marvel zombies outbreak like
you see zombie captain america fighting everyone
here there's also a zombie iron man wearing his
armor from avengers infinity war and it seems
like a zombified version of thanos black order
like this is cool obsidian behind him in what
seems like ebony ma over here in the background
too all zombies we also have a very big spider-man
doctor strange team-up coming during spider-man no
way home i know people wondering about when the
trailer's gonna drop more like spider-man no way
we're getting that trailer i've already done
a video about all the big new spider-man suit
reveals because one of the suit he's wearing is
a black suit i know everybody's wondering when
he's going to be wearing the symbiote not quite
the black suit you were expecting you see him
wielding magical runes like it's a spider-man suit
enhanced with doctor strange's magic and spells
allowing spider-man to wield magic briefly during
one or more of his fights with the sinister six
villains but as things start going out of control
looming over all this as things escalate it seems
like ultron is a much bigger batter threat in this
storyline like these stark tech drones look like a
similar version of the hammer tech drones from the
events of iron man 2 and just like the hammer tech
drones they also seem like they go rogue in attack
wakanda but because there's all this footage of
iron man working together with kilmonger what
might be happening here just based on the way
they cut the footage is the reason these drones go
off the rails might be because ultron just takes
over their programming and here's where the marvel
zombies plot starts to connect with the ultron
avengers age of ultron storyline so we know that
spider-man is zombie hunter spider-man well if
you watch this scene he's actually trying to web
up scarlet witch here who seems like she's gone
completely off the rails so she might actually
be zombie scarlet witch and they just introduce
ultron and vision as part of this age of
ultron storyline while this is all happening
like in the process of gaining control of all six
infinity stones and vision's body ultron tries to
attack wakanda to take their vibranium and then
throughout this winds up inadvertently creating
marvel zombies somehow also because doctor strange
supreme the dark doctor strange seems like he goes
completely off the rails he might have something
to do with the reason why the avengers turn into
zombies but during all this footage the attack
on wakanda kilmonger seems like he's teaming up
with shuri like she says our goals are temporary
aligned who seems like she's a little bit younger
maybe just because this is all happening a little
bit earlier in the timeline and also this might
be on the same version of earth where t'challa
was taken by yondu as a child with the ravagers
to become star-lord t'challa instead of growing
up to become black panther and kilmonger being
here to help save wakanda from ultron might be
how he becomes king of wakanda and black panther
i believe they're calling him king kilmonger on
the what if series like when they sell the toys
it'll say king kilmonger on the toys like after he
starts wearing this version of the black panther
costume we get way more footage of captain carter
fighting this giant tentacle creature and it
seems like just based on what's going on in the
background here this is taking place during the
events of world war ii because you see the hydro
banners behind her and it might have something
to do with red skull and arnhem zola messing with
the tesseract and things just going off the rails
like the tesseract contains the space stone so
it opens portals across the universe so maybe
the red skull is messing with it and accidentally
winds up allowing some creature from another world
to come to earth but the other cool thing here
that you may have noticed she's fighting with a
version of captain america's shield painted to
look like captain britain's shield because she
is kind of like a version of captain britain
during this she was part of the british army
during the events of the first captain america
movie and the sword she's wielding here might be
excalibur from marvel comics both captain britain
and the black knight have wielded excalibur in
the marvel universe before now the black knight's
origin story flows from the king arthur mythology
of the marvel universe we're gonna see mcu black
knight who's kit harrington during the eternals
movie he'll get a version of his origin story
during that maybe they also have a funny twist
on the myth of pulling the sword from the stone
when she becomes captain britain like she finds
it sitting inside a stone when she's in the middle
of a fight and just winds up yanking it out it's
sort of like a twist on the idea of thor's hammer
let he who is worthy wield the power of excalibur
either way if you spotted any of the big easter
eggs during this footage that i didn't talk
about in the video just write it below in the
comments this is just the beginning it'll get
way weirder and way cooler with all this big
multiverse storytelling that they're doing
after the loki series now you understand why
we saw loki episodes before we saw the what if
episodes like okay here's your introduction to
how the multiverse works now we're just going to
roll real hard on that they also just released
even more shanxi trailer footage so i'll do a
video for that tomorrow make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss anything
everyone click here for that other new shang
chi trailer and easter eggs and click here
for my new loki video about how iron man knew
about what was going on with kang inside the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!